>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT AS AMERICA
REALLY DID FOR A MOMENT SEEM ON
THE BRINK OF WAR WITH IRAN, SOME
ON TWITTER VOICED THEIR
DISPLEASURE BY TWEETING THE HASH
TAG "I VOTED FOR HILLARY."
HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF HAD TO
JOIN IN.
THE MESSAGE OF COURSE IS THAT
PRESIDENT HILLARY WOULD NOT BE
STARTING A WAR WITH IRAN.
IS THAT TRUE?
THE SINGLE MOST LIKELY PERSON IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA TO START
A WAR WITH IRAN.
HOW'D THAT WORK?
THEY'RE NOW SELLING SLAVES IN
DOWNTOWN TRIPOLI.
WATCH.
>> THAT IS THE LAND OF
UNCONFIRMED VIDEOS.
WE CAME, WE SAW, WE DIED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH YOU, DID IT?
>> I'M SURE IT DID.
>> Tucker:
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE KILLED THEM.
IT WAS HILARIOUS.
THAT COUNTRY FALLS APART AND
SLAVE MARKETS OPEN.
IF ANYTHING, HILLARY CLINTON'S
INTENTIONS TOWARD IRAN WERE EVEN
MORE BLOOD THIRSTY.
THE FIRST TIME SHE WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT SHE WARNED THAT
IRAN BETTER BE READY.
>> IF IRAN WERE TO LAUNCH A
NUCLEAR ATTACK ON ISRAEL, WHAT
WOULD THE RESPONSE BE.
IF I'M THE PRESIDENT, WE WILL
ATTACK IRAN.
WHATEVER STAGE OF DEVELOPMENT
THEY MIGHT BE IN THEIR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS DURING WHICH THEY MIGHT
CONSIDER FOOLISHLY LAUNCHING AN
ATTACK ON ISRAEL, WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO TOTALLY OBLITERATE THEM.
>> Tucker: JUST IN CASE YOU
DIDN'T REMEMBER THAT HILLARY
CLINTON WAS THE ERNEOCON.
ONE PERSON YOU WILL REMEMBER IS
TULSI GABBARD.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING.
I THINK SHE'S CAPABLE IN CERTAIN
WAYS.
I DON'T THINK EVERYTHING IS
ABOUT HER IS BAD.
>> YOU'RE NOT IMAGINING IT.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT SHE IS A
WARMONGER.
IT IS HER RECORD.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE TOTALLY RIGHT.
I LOVE THAT PHRASE.
>> YOU SHOWED THE CLIP ABOUT
LIBYA.
>> Tucker: YEP.
>> LOOKED TO HER INFLUENCE ON
GOING TO LAUNCH REGIME CHANGE
OVER IN SYRIA.
LIBYA, YOU LOOKED THROUGHOUT
OBVIOUSLY HER SUPPORT FOR THE
WAR IN IRAQ.
THROUGHOUT HER HISTORY.
HER TRACK RECORD IS WELL-KNOWN.
I THINK THIS IS WHY A LOT OF
PEOPLE BACK IN 2016 IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION DECIDED THAT
THEY WOULD VOTE FOR TRUMP
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE WAS SAYING ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL ABOUT ENDING
STUPID WARS AND BRINGING OUR
TROOPS HOME.
THE PROBLEM NOW, THOUGH, IS --
AND I'M OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND HEARING FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD VOTED FOR TRUMP
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THIS ISSUE
AND THEIR CONCERN ABOUT HOW
RATHER THAN ENDING STUPID WARS
AND BRINGING OUR TROOPS HOME,
WHAT THEY'RE SEEING IS MORE OF
OUR TROOPS BEING DEPLOYED TO THE
MIDDLE EAST.
NOW US, OUR COUNTRY, AT WAR WITH
IRAN.
THEY'RE COMING AND SAYING, HEY,
TULSI, WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT YOU
AS PRESIDENT, COMMANDER IN
CHIEF, WILL ACTUALLY END THESE
LONG-STANDING --
>> Tucker: WHAT SHOULD WE -- I
THINK YOU MAKE A FAIR POINT.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE DO GOING
FORWARD?
WE OPENED THE SHOW WITH A CALL
FOR COMPLETE WITHDRAWAL FROM
IRAN.
YOU SERVED THERE IN THE U.S.
ARMY.
>> I'M THE ONLY CANDIDATE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT WHO SERVED
IN UNIFORM IN IRAQ.
UNDERSTAND VERY CLEARLY THE
SITUATION THERE.
FOR DAYS NOW I'VE BEEN CALLING
FOR OUR TROOPS FROM IRAQ AND
SYRIA TO COME HOME.
AND HERE'S WHY.
WHEN WE DEPLOY OUR TROOPS
DOWNRAGE, WHEN THEY'RE IN HARM'S
WAY, THERE HAS TO BE A VERY
CLEAR MISSION THAT'S ACHIEVABLE.
WHERE THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THERE AND WHY, AND
THAT THAT MISSION ACTUALLY
SERVES OUR COUNTRY'S NATIONAL
SECURITY INTERESTS.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
IN IRAQ ESPECIALLY.
WE SEE HOW OUR TROOPS ARE THERE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
TO PREVENT A RESURGENT OF ISIS
AND AL QAEDA.
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THE U.S. COMMANDER IN IRAQ
ANNOUNCING OUR U.S. TROOPS WILL
NO LONGER BE PUTTING ANY EFFORTS
TOWARDS PREVENTING AL QAEDA AND
ISIS FROM MOUNTING A RESURGENCE
BECAUSE THEY WILL HAVE TO
DEDICATE ALL OF THEIR RESOURCES
AND EFFORTS TO MOUNTING A
DEFENSIVE POSTER AGAINST IRANIAN
FORCES --
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ENDORSING
IRAN, OBVIOUSLY.
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> Tucker: JUST A POINT OF FACT,
EVEN IN 2020, WASN'T IRAN ONE OF
THE FORCES THAT OVERCAME ISIS?
AM I IMAGINING?
>> YES.
AND IN IRAQ, THERE WAS THIS --
THIS KIND OF LONG-STANDING
UNEASY ALLIANCE BETWEEN U.S.
FORCES.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> IRAQI GOVERNMENT FORCES.
IRANIAN AND IRANIAN-BACKED SHIA
MILITIAS AND THE KURDS THERE ALL
COMING TOGETHER TO DEFEAT AND
PREVENT A RESURGENCE OF ISIS AND
AL QAEDA.
AND THIS IS WHERE,
UNFORTUNATELY, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ACTIONS ARE ACTUALLY UNDERMINING
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY IN TWO
IMPORTANT WAYS.
BECAUSE OUR TROOPS ARE NO LONGER
ABLE TO FOCUS ON THAT MISSION
OF -- OF PREVENTING ISIS FROM
GETTING A RESURGENCE, IT'S
CREATING AN OPEN FOR ISIS AND AL
QAEDA TO RECONSTITUTE THEMSELVES
AND TO POSE A THREAT TO OUR
FORCES, TO OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
PEOPLE IN THE REGION.
SECONDLY, IRAN HAS NOW SAID
THEY'RE NO LONGER COMPLYING WITH
RESTRICTIONS IN THE IRANIAN
AGREEMENT, SPEEDING TOWARDS
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN NUCLEAR
WEAPONS CAPABILITY WHICH PUTS US
AT GREATER RISK AND PUTS OUR
PARTNERS AND ALLIES IN THE
WORLD --
>> Tucker: I GET IT.
GETTING OUT OF --
>> THIS IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
GETTING OUR TROOPS OUT OF IRAQ
AND SYRIA IS ESSENTIAL.
THE LONGER THAT THEY ARE THERE,
THE MORE LIKELY IT IS THAT THEY
ARE AT RISK AND THAT WE WILL END
UP IN THIS ENDLESS TIT FOR TAT
BACK AND FORTH QUAGMIRE OF A WAR
WITH PEOPLE WONDERING WHAT IS IT